qu'est ce que c'est devenir une grande
championne d'équitation et
voilà mes parents ont trouvé cet
entraîneur pour réaliser mes rêves je
les ai rencontrés à l'âge de 9 ans et il
m'a clairement dit qu'il pouvait être
l'homme qui allait réaliser mes rêves
d'enfant je sors sauf que effectivement
il les a réalisés comme les à briser
puisque à l'âge de 14 ans il m'a il m'a
invité à une démonstration lors d'un
pont pas ndour donc à un grand ara et
j'étais tout seul avec lui et à
l'auberge avec une seule chambre donc
j'ai dormi avec lui et il en a profité
pour me violer toutes en m'expliquant
que c'était normal qu'il fallait pas que
j'ai peur et que c'était quelqu'un
c'était quelqu'un qui j'avais totalement
confiance puisque un entraîneur un un
père un grand père une fille ce soir
éternelle qui vous aviez une extrême
confiance vous aviez totalement
confiance en lui il à se tourner ce jour
là qu'est ce qui se passe tous tout
s'écroule en fait non parce que je ne
sais pas ce qui se passe moi je connais
pas c'est parce que c'est que de l'amour
de ses passages sur des caresses à 14
ans on sait pas je voyais que
entraînement chevaux et c'est tout
le
quand il m'explique que c'est quelque
chose de normal que c'est un secret et
que j'en ai besoin pour ma vie de femme
et que vaut mieux que ce soit un homme
comme lui qui m'apprennent ces choses là
plutôt que d'un petit jeune qui gâche
tout
bah moi je n'étais pas là l'enfant
qu'ils allaient faire des soirées
pyjamas des boues qui sortait avec les
mêmes peines que j'avais pas le dos à
nos chers parce que vous avez plus de
vous entraîniez beaucoup dans ses
sorties mais moi je vois les
championnats du monde ce serait ce que
j'ai vu c'était la seule personne qui
allait réaliser mes rêves mais il
fallait passer par des étapes alors il
va racheter votre entraîneur il va
rester monde en avait parlé à vos
parents
j'ai essayé avec des mots d'enfant
comment ou leur ai dit quoi vous
après la fac à l'entrée de la fac que je
leur ai dit qu'il fallait que je parle
du centre équestre parce que c'était
plus possible pouvait plus vivre dans
ces conditions ils m'ont répété que
c'était un caprice et qu'il fallait pas
c'était quelqu'un qui m'a emmené vers la
victoire donc c'était quelqu'un de 2 à
leurs yeux il a été la garde élastique
il est resté votre entraîneur et ça va
se reproduire j'ai bien fait de mes 14
ans jusqu'à mes 19 ans et m'a violée
assez régulièrement et si je le faisais
pas c'était la sanction me supprimer mes
chevaux il m'emmenait plus en
compétition et m'humilier devant tout le
monde
et j'ai dû rester dans ses griffes
jusqu'à mes 27 ans je voulais pas partir
avant il y avait cette notion d'emprise
qui était très importante et j'ai pu
partir quand mes parents ont acheté un
centre équestre à côté de fontainebleau
et là je suis parti du centre équestre
avec mes chevaux et j'ai appris que il
avait fait ça aussi amont à la petite
stagiaire
on était deux à
essayer de comprendre ce qui nous est
arrivé à mettre des mots sur ce qui
s'est passé ce jour et on a porté
plainte en 2013 alors il a été il était
reconnu coupable en 2020 alors en 2013
il ya un classement sans suite il a été
bon il a été auditionné mais placé en
garde à vue
je sais pas ce qui s'est passé pendant
cette procédure bien sûr victimes ne
sont jamais mis au courant et en 2020
2014 un classement sans suite je me suis
tu pendant 7 ans parce que je me suis
dit que la justice avait tranché et
quand j'ai vu la parole de sarah à la
télévision j'ai été comme poignardée sur
place alors très bizarrement c'était une
soirée j'étais avec mes enfants j'étais
en train de passer l'aspirateur et là je
vois à la télévision le visage de sarah
et là je me suis arrêtée net et j'essaie
de comprendre ce qu'elle était en train
de dire elle est en train de dire la
honte change de camp tout ça est en fait
je comprenais pas mais pourquoi moi je
me suis tu pendant sept ans si sarah
aller là à la télévision et qu'elle vit
il faut parler pour se reconstruire pour
rester de de vivre correctement sans
être brisée et humilié il faut parler
j'essaie de comprendre déjà j'ai vu
qu'elle avait elle avait
fait un livre non je suis pas du tout
une grande lectrice je ne nie pas je ne
lis rien dans les faits un très beau
livre tout cas mon corps paul luis etc
voilà si c'est vrai que j'ai écrit un
livre me raconter j'ai du mal à le lire
encore c'est vrai ouais j'ai acheté le
livre de sarah et j'ai lu le livre en
une soirée et j'ai corner toutes les
pages parce que toute sa vie c'était la
vôtre la mienne tout ça et j'ai eu du
mal à me remettre j'ai essayé de la
joindre de joindre emmanuelle anizon qui
a écrit son bouquin oui j'ai essayé de
tout retourner de tout bousculer pour
essayer de de rouvrir ce dossier est de
comprendre comment on pouvait la libérer
cette parole parce que l'on sait pas si
on ne nous explique pas on sait pas
et grâce à emmanuel qui a écrit l'auteur
klaxons voilà emmanuelle anizon 70 a
écrit un article dans le nouvel obs oui
tout s'est déclenché tout à tous est
ouvert c'est à dire que la justice qui
m'avait fermer les yeux a rouvert mon
dossier jeunesse et sport qui voulait
pas m'écouter parce que j'avais aussi
dit qu'il y avait mon agresseur qui est
en train de de travailler encore avec
des enfants qui l'habitait à 40 minutes
de chez moi donc je savais qu'il avait
pleins pleins d'enfants des ados des des
femmes je l'avais qu'il avait habitué à
agir vite j'ai eu des auditions j'ai été
entendu et il a été mis en examen il a
été placé sous contrôle judiciaire on
lui a enlevé son autorisation d'exercer
définitivement ce qui est assez rare
et il a été condamné il est décédé
quelques temps alors voilà le coc vide
là l'a attrapée
voilà il est mort le 27 avril
alors c'est dur de c'est dur de se dire
en fait je ne savais pas si j'étais
contente qu'il soit mort parce qu'ils me
verrai plus jamais ce qu'ils venaient me
voir en concours il m'observait il reste
à côté de moi il me suivait sur les
réseaux sociaux frire c'était vraiment
un intérieur jusqu'au bout et d'un autre
côté je me disais en fait la personne
qui m'a aidé le plus au monde qui m'a
appris tout et en même temps qui m'a
brisé est mort mais cette emprise était
toujours là
comment faire pour se défaire meilleure
chose eh ben c'est pas si simple